hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy welcome to the uh the homeroom
live stream uh you might notice i've
upgraded my equipment at felipe's
request and so this is this is like now
in hd so this is a very very very
exciting day
so we have a very exciting guest today
we have mayam bialik who is an actress a
neuroscientist now a
author and a podcast creator and we'll
talk a lot about that but before we jump
into that conversation i will give my
standard announcements a reminder that
uh we are khan academy is a
not-for-profit so if you're in a
position to do so please think about uh
going to khan academy.org slash donate
and making a donation
i want to also give a special shout out
to several organizations that stepped up
especially when they realized that
during the pandemic more people than
ever were relying on khan academy and
that's awesome but it was also driving
our costs up our server cost we wanted
to accelerate a bunch of content so
special thanks to bank of america att
google.org novartis fastly and general
motors
and last but not least i want to give
everyone a reminder that there's a
version of this live stream that is
available in podcast form wherever you
get your podcasts homeroom with sal
the podcast
so with that i am very excited to
introduce maya mayam welcome
thank you i hope i'm not late to
homeroom
we need to get a bell so that people
like you know they're in mentally the
right the right place yeah so
there's so much uh that we can chat
about i'm trying to level it so that our
our shoulders are around this i
appreciated it i felt like i was looking
down at you
which you can do um
so there's so much to talk about you
know
we've gotten to know each other
virtually over several we were on a
panel together a couple of months ago
and then
i was on on your podcast yesterday um
and there's a lot of stuff to overlap
but i i did i did tell you when i first
met you and i'm not normally like into
this whole celebrity thing uh but
there's something about growing up
watching blossom and i know you've done
other things in your life since then and
you know you've gotten phds you're a
neuroscientist but um as i said
yesterday i i i try to play it cool when
i'm around you uh well
i think i told you the first time we met
when we were on that panel together
you are the celebrity to me um my kids
have been using khan academy for years
and it's an enormous it's an enormously
important part of our lives and when i
told my kids that i was gonna be on a
panel with you we all freaked out so it
is really my honor to be in homeroom
with you
well
sounds like sounds like a win-win then
well there's so much to talk about and i
encourage anyone watching to put your
questions in we have team members who
can surface the questions to myself and
mayam but you know
you have a an eclectic background there
are not a lot of
neuroscientist
author
uh uh uh actresses in the world
how do you like it like what do you do
do you connect with all of those
identities are you more one than the
other and and then like did you think
you would be have this this hodgepodge
of of things to do no i mean i identify
as you know the grandchild of immigrants
like when i think of who i am you know
my grandparents came to this country um
during the pogroms leading up to
you know the holocaust so um that that's
you know i'm my parents daughter and i'm
my grandparents grandchild and um
you know everything that happened once
they hit ellis island you know is is
really my story everybody's got a story
um for me i was raised in a very
colorful you know first generation
american
household and
my native language is yiddish that's the
language of eastern european jews you
know i was raised really spanning
several cultures and
i was a very uh
problem-solving kind of child and i felt
very comfortable on a stage and i became
an actor you know as a young person
but
truly i'm you know i'm a thinker and i
found math and science late in life and
fought really hard to be able to be a
scientist when it doesn't come naturally
to you and you're told that if it
doesn't come naturally it's not for you
it's very hard to try and break into
that at 15 and 16 which is what i did so
i became a neuroscientist it took you
know 12 years between undergrad and grad
school
and i had my first son in grad school
he's now 15 and i have a 12 year old so
i'm a mom you know like that's really
what my life is i'm a mom and yes i i
have written books i do a lot of things
um
not to make ends meet but to sort of
satisfy the different parts of my brain
and my life and um yeah i guess i i'm
all of those hyphenates you know i'm
also a lactation educator counselor i've
been that for about 13 years and so i
speak to women about breastfeeding and
labor like i do a lot of different
things because i just feel like that's
my human experience
well it's it's fascinating
so
i mean take us on your journey a little
bit uh you know a lot of people watching
are our young people trying to figure
out what to do with their lives you at a
very young age i mean how did you get
into acting
no my my parents were public school
teachers and documentary filmmakers my
parents were both english teachers my
mother was a preschool you know early
childhood educator
um
i i didn't grow up in a hollywood house
you know i grew up in a
kind of a crummy rental house in
hollywood and you know was part of the
busing program of the 70s and 80s that
took kids from uh rougher neighborhoods
and and took us to neighborhoods where
uh the there were more educational
opportunities so i grew up just like a
normal kid you know um
you know just living um you know with
parents who were teachers like and i was
in school plays in elementary school and
really liked it felt safe on a stage i
wasn't one of those like super hammy
kids like look at me i'm amazing like i
didn't think that i just knew that there
was a safety
uh for me that i felt when you know
honestly when making other people happy
like and there's a very interesting
psychology to why some actors really do
act because we want other people to feel
something and that was kind of what it
was like for me and i knew that there
were kid actors it didn't occur to me
that no one looked like me in 1986 and
that maybe i wouldn't have success um i
indeed did not have success in
traditional things that kid actors do
like commercials because back then there
was something called all-american and i
didn't look like it
and how so how did you fall into that
did someone just discover you was there
a ah
no it's literally like the like the 1986
story is that um my parents typed a
letter on a typewriter and took a
picture of me like just in the backyard
a cute headshot
and they they mailed it there was no
computers that we had then um you know
there wasn't anything to email they
looked in the yellow pages and just
found kids agents and literally sent my
picture on this letter to nine different
kids agents and i ended up picking an
agent who um
happened to have a lot of quite i mean
quite famous kids have come out of her
agency neil patrick harris and johnny
galecki who i was with um the big bang
theory and um mario lopez was with her
so i ended up just going on auditions
and i was in a lot of sitcoms from the
from the 80s and you know things like
webster
macgyver facts of life
and then i was cast to play the young
bette midler in beaches when i was 12
and it came out when i was 13 and then
after that i did blossom from 14 to 19.
i have to find these clips you've just
like my entire childhood just came back
to me in that one and my head didn't
change size i had this enormous head and
a little twig body and then i just sort
of grew into my head
i have a similar experience actually i'm
three inches taller than my wife but our
shoulders are at the same height
so i'm all head
and i've always i've always been and i
see it in my children like when they're
born they can't touch the top of their
heads because their heads are
the same size as mine
so so i mean but your parents
you know they must have seen something
in you at that age to kind of go through
the trouble of taking your head shot and
and sending yeah i mean
yeah i think look i definitely
um i was raised in a traditional jewish
house and there is a lot of
uh performance you know to a lot of
aspects of our culture meaning you know
when we read the torah which is the old
testament it's chanted and you know a
bar mitzvah is a very presentational
kind of you know we we sing our bible
like we are a presentation you know
passover involves reciting the four
questions and you know being able to do
that so i definitely had a lot of
opportunities and i was in dance as a
lot of you know young kids are young
girls so i was a ballerina from the time
i was four i was in classical english
ballet and um you know i danced and sure
i was charismatic but i think a lot of
parents think their kids are you know
cute and charismatic i don't know they
said they always
you know felt like i had something but i
i really don't know because like my mom
still is like you're prettier than any
woman in the world and it's like i know
that's not true so you don't know if you
can trust your parents
and and what was it like i mean you know
there's this stereotype of of people who
child actors you know they're they hit
notoriety early in their lives maybe
their identity gets caught up in it and
you're kind of clinging on to it and
life throws interesting things at you
how did you deal were you conscientious
of that when you were
10 11 12 13 years old um
yeah i mean because i come from you know
i mean at least for us like i come from
an immigrant mentality where like you go
to school you get an education and i
always had this notion that like
everything is fleeting you know the
success is fleeting like everything you
know it's very it's a very zen buddhist
philosophy um you know this too shall
pass and so my education was very
important to me it was very important to
my parents who were both teachers they
didn't want me being on a set you know
for many months of the year to to
take the place of the education that i
still needed so you know they they went
to a lot of work there was a woman named
janie teller who was in charge of my
education and hired me different um
tutors for every subject and you know
got me some incredible really really
amazing tutors especially for my science
subjects and that's how i fell in love
with science so um i really i was never
really taken with like the fame and the
money parts of show business
um i i was raised you know as a kind of
you know small intellectual that's just
how my dad and my mom raised me so i
knew i wanted to be around people who
were thinking deeply and while there are
many intelligent people in the industry
i really thrived in in a public
university system you know i went to
ucla and yes it was intimidating to be
in large classes for you know for a lot
of our core classes we were often with
300 people in a class but i made the
most of the you know you're you're then
divided into sections and so you know i
made use of office hours and i loved
that
environment i'm a very organized person
when it comes to school work so i you
know everything was color coded and my
assignment notebooks and all those
things and i really just i wanted more
of a normal life than i think the
industry could provide me with
and there's questions a ton of questions
are coming in off of youtube and
facebook and this is related you know
crystal gross writes from youtube
what is your advice for kids who want to
become scientists or have careers in
math but they struggle with courses
geared towards that they have the dream
but not the grades and you had mentioned
and you just mentioned that at least
initially you were struggling a little
bit or maybe you felt a little bit of a
an imposter syndrome how do you navigate
that
um
you know i think part of it is um you
know there's there's two components
for me you know there's two components
one was the skill set and the other was
the confidence and for me kind of the
the confidence had to come first meaning
believing that i had the right to to
learn these kind of subjects and that
there's not just one way to learn them
so for me um working with a tutor was
extremely helpful having more of a you
know an intimate kind of one-on-one
experience was a real help for me um in
the time that i grew up there were not a
lot of women um in in stem
you know at least in in ways that i had
access to so having a female tutor was
also very empowering because i could see
someone else who had been working at it
she was 19 when i met her and i was like
yeah 15. um but you know she was in
college and she came from a family an
immigrant family from iran and
education was very important to her
family and all her sisters got to go to
either med school or dental school so
she's now an oral surgeon but having um
that that relationship where someone was
teaching me the way i learned was really
helpful and i think also the pacing of
how classes were traditionally taught
didn't always work for me in those
subjects you know english i could get
like that like that wasn't a problem
sociology anthropology like psychology
all that stuff that wasn't the issue you
know numbers and formulas was hard for
me at the pacing that things were set at
so i did need to work harder and
honestly i had to work harder all the
way um through my undergrad and all the
way into grad school meaning there were
certain things that came a lot easier to
me but you know i worked in a genetics
lab conversions were always hard for me
even working in a genetics lab so there
were still things that i had to always
keep up on
and what was it you know what was the
moment that you said neuroscience i want
to be a neuroscientist even though it
might have some of these speed bumps
along the way that you might not have
felt are like you're
you know
what wasn't the easiest thing for you
so the first thing that really you know
kind of
captivated me in science was um
really cell biology you know uh dna like
once i got to understand and like once
it clicked like oh
it's this and then the histones and the
things and you know like i hope that's
still true i mean i haven't studied dna
so um that's i was interested in nature
versus nurture which was a popular you
know kind of a popular science topic in
the 90s like what makes us who we are i
know for young people it's like duh but
back then there was a lot of discussion
about it and the god's honest truth is
that um i wanted to study biology when i
got you know to ucla but because my um
calculus and my chemistry were not um
at an appropriately high level i had to
take
really remedial i mean it was remedial
chemistry and remedial calculus and so
until i did those things i couldn't
register for biology so i was so
frustrated i was so embarrassed that
like here i was wanting to be a
scientist and i couldn't even start the
core curriculum but one of the classes
that didn't require my chemistry and
calculus to be completed
was a class called psychobiology and the
first half of the class was taught by a
psychology professor
who specialized in things like uh you
know conditioned response like pavlovian
stuff very interesting very important
you know attachment theory great the
second half of the course was taught by
professor eran zeidel and he was in the
psychology department but he taught the
neurophysiology of the the nervous
system and in particular
electrophysiology
and when i saw this is my moment when i
saw that action potential chart and i
saw that electrical impulses are what
allow for the release of sodium and
potassium and all of these ions that
lead to a chain reaction that cause
further electrical responses and that's
how we perceive the world i literally
said
that's the level i want to understand
the universe at that level and that is
when i decided to become a
neuroscientist
i am so excited to hear you say that i
think we're going to take that clip of
what you just said and on khan academy
where we introduce
action potential sodium potassium pump i
will teach that class with joy i've done
it before i would love to
and even just your answer right now you
know the number one thing is people
there's you know i always tell folks
that you get to learn all of this stuff
that you know the the what's in the
textbook is hundreds of years of human
knowledge and the people who dedicate
their lives to discovering what's in
that textbook would have killed to have
that textbook but so many kids are like
oh i got a little about the sodium
potassium pump but
when they hear you out of all of what
see you were on macgyver that sounds
exciting but
i heard more excitement in your voice
about the sodium potassium action
potentials and neurons than macgyver
well and also like i had the opportunity
i taught neuroscience i designed a
curriculum for junior high and high
school students in our homeschool
community and i taught for about five
years before big bang theory um i taught
in our community and
you know to be able to be a science
communicator is a very special and you
know obviously it's one thing to know
the material but to be to be either
gifted or taught the skills to
communicate it to other people and to
explain it until you see
that they get it it is an exceptional
it's an exceptional moment of like a
microcosm of creation you know you're
creating
an an inspired
thought in someone who previously didn't
understand it and when i think of the
concepts that were hardest for me i
remember learning the optical system and
the the way the the ganglion neurons and
the american neurons and all those
things line up it is so difficult and
how it's like a constantly generating
system that needs to have a negative
feedback loop and i remember how hard it
was but when you get it
that feeling it's better than applause
it's better than an emmy like i i've
never won an emmy i've only been
nominated four times but that
satisfaction of the human mind grasping
something of that enormity there
literally is nothing like it i mean
giving birth was enormously significant
but it's on that level of like wow
well now you've you've made me feel
better because you know i haven't given
birth i've modeled it in my mind but i i
have had that experience which you have
which is when something clicks and you
understand the universe in another way
like that is what it means to be human
that is what it means to experience life
and uh you know i know i know you you
might be
you know saying that you would love to
teach i we will talk later we we're
doing a big push on science on khan
academy
i don't know where to don't know where
to find you for sure so all sorts of
questions coming in actually before i
get to more questions i i am curious you
know when you were
at ucla or into grad school and you're
learning the neuroscience you're
thinking about becoming a neuroscientist
what was in the back of your mind like
education's important it's a safety net
that's my backup
in case you know hollywood isn't what it
what i i hope it could be or is it the
other way around he's like no i want to
be a neuroscientist yeah on the side
i'll i'll do a couple of cameos or be in
a couple of shows here and there
no when i left the industry i was 19 i
was two years out of high school i went
to a very um
you know college prep style honestly
junior high and high school um here in
los angeles and um you know i was i was
geared to go to college and to be honest
when i left the industry i i didn't have
active plans to return to it um i wanted
to you know live in an apartment and you
know walk to campus and and meet other
students i was very active in the jewish
student union and um you know i i
studied japanese history and i studied
philosophy like i i had the best time
there and i you know met the person that
i then you know married and had children
we met in calculus class like i was
living a totally different life i would
go to school in pajamas like most
science students did like i loved my
life and
um i originally wanted to go to med
school i wanted to um i wanted to study
psychiatry
god's honest truth i could not get
higher than a b minus in organic
chemistry and um
that really was the weiter class for med
school and you know i i hate to say
those who can't go to med school go to
grad school but um i did i made the
decision to be a more of a research
academic i was not planning on going
back to the industry um you know like i
said i taught after getting my doctorate
acting is a very interesting world but
it's not
it's not intellectually stimulating the
way
being a scientist was
and to be perfectly honest you know
having my first son which i did after my
data collection for my my thesis project
and i essentially wrote my thesis while
laying down breastfeeding um it was the
decision to leave academia because i was
choosing to be home with my son that
actually shifted kind of the trajectory
of my life and that's a very difficult
decision i can't say it was the right
decision for everyone uh but for me it
was the decision and for my husband at
the time that was the decision we made
and so i i tutored you know and i i also
taught piano i taught hebrew i did a lot
of things while also being you know the
primary caregiver for my my son um and
then had another one uh right after i
got my doctorate so my life really
shifted in terms of the academic track
but i was still teaching and because of
the united states healthcare system i
did um return to acting to literally do
enough work so that i could get my
insurance back through screen actors
guild which is excellent insurance
for insurance that's the most pragmatic
reason i've ever heard
well someone said like we literally got
mayam bialik on the big bang theory
because of the failure of our health
care system
you always have better health care
health care than i imagined as the
screen actors guild that's good i'm
happy to hear that
i mean and i mean you know
when talking was fascinating because i
listed three things author actress
neuroscientist but clearly mother very
important very large role of your life
now you are also doing this podcast
bialik breakdown which is about mental
health um
i mean it sounds like you are this poly
math type person you're taking on a lot
of different projects
why the podcast now and why this focus
on mental health
you know my my interest
has really always hovered around mental
health challenges i grew up in a home
that had mental illness as as many homes
do
um and you know i think many families
have it but we don't really call it that
or you know even when i listen to
stories of my grandparents generation
you know oh this one was like this and
it's like that was schizophrenia you
know we didn't know to call it that but
someone who hears voices like that's
actually a clinical diagnosis you know
so um i i've always had an interest in
the way we react to those environments
and what's genetic and what's
environmental i do have my share of
challenges and i've been very open about
it but it was really last year you know
when when the world got very small in
many ways as many of us were home
that so many people that i knew started
experiencing
in particular anxiety and panic and they
honestly didn't even know what to call
it and i was thinking how many people
are experiencing challenges that that
are lacking just the basic information
about what's going on um so my partner
jonathan and i we started a myembalex
breakdown really to start breaking down
some of the terms and um some of the
misconceptions also that people have
about mental health and this isn't like
i've figured it all out come and listen
to how i'm going to tell you to make
your life better this is i still live
with anxiety i have struggled with
depression i am on the ocd spectrum
those are just true things about me and
i still get to figure out what works and
what doesn't and the notion of you know
mind body syndrome and and the things
that that eastern medicine and eastern
cultures have known about for thousands
of years that we're finally catching on
to is also something that that jonathan
and i are looking to explore meaning
there is science to acupuncture there is
science to why certain smells do certain
things to your brain those are real
things and if there are things that we
can do before we get to let's say
medication and diagnosis and dsm this
we should all know about those things i
think it should be a human right you
know for for us to be educated about
how our mind is connected to our body
and how that impacts our mental health
so we talk to experts in the field every
episode or people who are experts in
their own journey and their own
struggles and sometimes those are famous
celebrities um but it is available um on
spotify or wherever you get podcasts and
we also do broadcast on my youtube
channel which has almost a million
followers so we encourage people also to
sign up if you'd like to see me and
jonathan we wear matching outfits every
episode
i didn't catch that they were matching
episodes that's uh
matching outfits i mean it's a very
important thing and you know i have to
say that i was one of these people you
know we grew up in a culture where
you know you you can you kind of take
pride on i'm functional i'm i'm saying
et cetera et cetera and then you're like
oh you know these are other people's
problems uh and yeah i think as you know
every family has a lot in it that you
know usually you try to hide and and not
have transparent to the rest of the
world uh but i and i mentioned it on
your podcast and i think i mentioned it
here too is
you know my first real glimpse
personally was about five years ago
where i think frankly because of stress
at work and other things i started
getting incredibly claustrophobic i
wasn't sleeping as much as you know i
found myself going for runs at three in
the morning because that's all i could
do to get rid of some of my my energy um
and and that was the first time that i
realized that i shouldn't just like
identify myself as a functional person
that we all have and it creeps up on you
it creeps up on you it's like a frog in
boiling water and so it's really
important you know for me and i
mentioned yesterday for me meditation
when i meditated almost out of
desperation to not get claustrophobic in
planes which clearly had to travel a lot
for my job
it opened up a whole new world for me so
not only did it help solve the
claustrophobia and the anxiety and the
panic i would get in small spaces but it
helped open my my life and other really
powerful beautiful ways that i would
never have done had i had i not
experienced that so
so
happy that you are taking this mantle
like you know
people should be talking about this
because it you know
when we talk about mental health people
always talk about from the deficit side
of things but it can also add uh and and
and gives us base for it so so in the i
in the time we we have left and there's
so much so many questions that are that
are coming up about all all sorts of
things uh maybe you know from nish
nish786 what are some challenges you
face becoming a neuroscientist what
advice do you have for people who want
to follow a path like yours you
mentioned a few of them but i'm sure
there are others
yeah i mean you know honestly being
being a woman in a field that is is
typically male
can have its challenges um you know
there are there are women in situations
far far far far more challenging um than
than what i experienced and that what
many women experience but i think it is
definitely you know something to
acknowledge that um the standards for
women um tend to be um
very um
very limited in terms of um there's
there's a few ways that people are often
comfortable with women being in the
sciences and so that's something just to
kind of you know that you have to keep
in mind um i think also you know
deciding when and how to have children
was was particularly challenging and not
every woman wants to have children or
there are a lot of ways to to be a mom
without you know physically giving birth
but it's definitely you know a set of um
challenges that that i had to kind of
plan and time the best that i could and
you know i'm i'm not a great test taker
and there are exams required um there
was the gre which was very challenging
um to get into grad school and then we
had qualifying exams um our first year
uh two of which i needed to do
remediation on which was humiliating but
also just part of the process you know i
um i was called into the uh the head of
the department's office after my first
year and she said we you know all of
neuroscience were kind of surprised and
disappointed because you were an a
student and yet you did not do well on
your exams and you know i kind of hung
my head and um you know it was
definitely um hard and i think that's
also just because it it wasn't something
that came naturally naturally to me you
know that kind of thinking um so those
were you know i cried in her office it
was not a pretty moment um
but i i made it through
i i mean were there moments where you
thought you were going to just give up
or or did was there
yeah i mean i think anyone who's done a
phd it's like literally
people forget also i did a phd when
there wasn't really computer access to
articles or information we had to
physically go to the library which at
ucla we call it the stacks and it's like
a 10 story building and you would get a
little card that you would have to put
cash on so that you could make the
copies and you'd be in the middle of
some article and then you'd run out of
money on your card and by the time you
got back someone shelved the book that
you were working on so it was a lot of
physical labor and also
formatting a 300 page thesis is also no
small feat and
we we also didn't have all the tools
that are now available to do that the
formatting alone made me want to not get
my doctorate like that was the level of
proficiency i felt i had with that
aspect so i know those sound silly but
when you've been doing research for six
years and you're just trying to finish
and you have a newborn the last thing
you want to be told by the office where
you submit is that you know your margins
are off on page three and you have to
start all over with your formatting
i just can imagine the thoughts i mean i
actually can't imagine because
you know one of my friends from college
actually i've known him from childhood
he he was you know i got to know him he
beat me at a math competition so i'm
like i'm going to hang out with this guy
he beat me in 10th grade and then he
actually ended up being the first
president like the ceo and president of
khan academy when we started so very
close friend of mine
um but i remember when and he you know
super super smart guy uh and but i
remember he he had his first child a
year before i had mine or we had ours
and i remember one day he was just like
you know his hair is all the style he's
like sal i don't know you know
everything else has been kind of easy
you know i i can i can crush tests i
mean he is a good test taker you know
he's like it's just been easy he's a
triple major at mit he's easy he's like
with this this this child rearing
it's hard
and everyone does it how come everyone
does it like
if it's so hard for me how can everyone
else
and he's right but the fact that you
were doing that while
getting a phd
he's he's a he's a total nerd by first
they're both kind of nerdy but my first
born he was literally he was raised on
thesis
there might be something to that you
know people like play mozart while their
kids are like you know if you do a
thesis if you're at the copying machine
while they're getting the radiation it
might might do something
you know
just a as a maybe maybe to finish off
you know a lot of people ask a lot of
questions your views of the future 2021
what are you looking forward to
you have so many projects so many
interests yeah what do you kind of see
is the next phase of of your life next
few you know next 10 years say
um gosh you know i hope to retire by
then
i'm just so tired um
you know i'm i'm 45 and my kids are 12
and 15.
so in many ways you know my entire life
is kind of centered around
you know where they are in their
academics and in their life like my
younger ones preparing for his bar
mitzvah so i'm tutoring him for that and
um you know my older son will likely be
starting you know online community
college courses that's what a lot of
homeschool high schoolers do um
so you know i think of where they will
be you know in the next 10 years um i
definitely i'm working on a new show
it's called call me cat and it's it's
fun i'm having a really great time doing
it so i'm hoping that that we get a
second season of that and honestly this
podcast is really it's really my passion
you know it sounds so like pretentious
but it is it is my passion to talk about
mental health and to be able to you know
maybe one day be able to advocate on a
larger you know um dc level for for
mental health access that's something i
would really really love to see as as
what i get to work on um but you know
honestly i um i miss traveling and it's
you know i'm very conservative i guess
when it comes to um covid as many
scientists tend to be so i'm also really
just kind of cautious about what this
year is going to look like and i think a
lot of people don't understand the
importance of the vaccine i think a lot
of people don't understand the
implications of not getting the vaccine
i've been very vocal about that i put
out a youtube video about the importance
of that so i'm kind of cautious about
what this year will look like because
it's been a long time since i've been to
a supermarket you know and i'm ready to
get back out there but just waiting
no i i i definitely hear you my i live
with my obviously my wife and my
mother-in-law my wife's a doctor and so
she's gotten her vaccine now my
mother-in-law just got her booster so i
am now the major risk factor in the
house i'm going to see how much care
about me they were careful before the
first time you've been the most
dangerous person in your house
that's right that's right i like that
i'm glad you see that in me um so
my thank you so you know this was a this
was a a a suit i could talk for hours i
know everyone listening could could hear
and and listen to your your wisdom for
hours uh but you know thank you so much
for joining and i hope in that ten years
and i'm serious we should explore a
little bit of science education uh one
way or the other i would absolutely love
that and again my children would lose
their mind
let's do it all right well miami alec
thank you so much for joining us this
was thank you so much so
so thank thanks everyone for joining
hopefully you found that i you know i've
i've only had a a few times i've got got
the privilege of hanging out with mayam
but she just has incredible energy and i
think it's very powerful when you can
see someone who can throw across so many
genres and break so many different types
of stereotypes so hopefully you enjoyed
that as much as as i did
so um thank you for joining uh i know
i'm doing these a little bit more
sporadically than i was doing uh earlier
this year uh but uh we look forward to
see you soon i'm gonna go on a little
bit of a vacation next week and then uh
the week after we will back be back on
this live stream so thanks everyone for
joining and have a have a good weekend
you